hi can I come in
nicest thing you how are you hi Louise
and congratulations on your book
are you very proud of it hello Lily
thank you for having me and your lovely
lounge I'm very very proud of it I feel
like it's like a little baby of mine
I've been working so hard on for months
and months and now it's here I'm very
very excited which is your best bit I
think I quite like the pages about
dating and boys I think they're the
funniest and I like all the kitty marks
on it here will you be giving it two for
Christmas
well since it's summer now I'm going to
be giving out to a lot of people my
friends our family already so I don't
know if they'll be anyone left to give
it to you for Christmas
so perhaps I'll have to make some new
friends through now Christmas and then I
could give it to that grant oh that was
a good question I liked it no one's
asking that question yet okay
now then talk to you about your beastie
okay what's the best part of your daily
be tivity do you know what I think the
best part is actually taking off my
makeup because sometimes when you've
been wearing a lot of makeup all day I
know because you've got a little bit of
lip gloss on I hope you're not wearing
more more makeup than that at this age
but when you've got a lot it makes your
face a little bit tired and like you
just want to clean it all off so when
you take it all off and then you put
moisturizer on your skin feels amazing
but I do like at the very beginning as
well when you've just finished and look
at your face you think yes I've done it
I'm happy with that that's a nice
feeling too would you ever dye your hair
I color other than pink lots of people
ask that and I don't think I will I
actually put a little bit of purple in
it at the beginning of the year but it
mixed with the pink and it couldn't
quite tell and I think sometimes what I
did mint or turquoise but I think that
wouldn't look as nice as pink and I've
got a lot of pink clothes so right now I
can't imagine doing another pillow do
you think I should do another color no I
think
I will do that what is your favorite
color lipstick pink it's pink because
because I've got pink bits in my hair is
hard to wear red because pink and red
clash so I don't if you noticed at
Christmas time I let all the pink run
out of my hair so it was all blonde all
over so I wear red lipstick and then in
the spring I bought the pink tips back
so that I could have pinks and oranges
but I haven't worn red for a while I
think it's too Christmasy now I'm going
to talk to you a bit about fashion okay
one of my favorite topics you go what
are your favorite clothes shops have you
heard of a sauce yes it's an online one
I really love that because they do
clothes for all shapes and sizes and
they really flatter I think very nice
and I always go into H&M and spend money
because they're too nice and I always
pick up bits oh I think I desperately
need and I always find some treasure in
Primark do you prefer online shopping or
in real life shopping real life I think
because you can do that with friends
when we go on the red carpet does it
feel exciting on nerve-racking really
exciting really really exciting but I
always think will this be the red carpet
that I fall over on because I haven't
done it yet but I am prone to falling
over so it's going to happen one of
these days and when I when it does it'll
be a disaster how did you feel when
Darcy was burned actually when Darcy was
born I had a very difficult delivery and
it took a long time and a lot of days so
well she was actually born I was too
exhausted to feel very much at all but
my best feeling ever was when I had an
ultrasound which is when you go in and
they they use that machine to take a
picture inside your tummy the black and
white one and they tell me I was having
a baby girl and that's my favorite
moment ever ever ever in my whole life
because I really secretly wanted a girl
and I was so excited because then you
would get a little tiny baby girl to
play with all of my life
and now I'm going to talk to you about
flopping okay good good topic what do
you watch on YouTube oh that's a good
one I watch I always really like to
watch Joe and TAS these videos and I
watch a lot of family vloggers because I
like to see people's family and let them
interaction between parents and children
and I watch a lot of beauty when such
series i watch Hanna max see what church
is little baby what do you watch Joanna
so well oh you're thank you timeless yep
Tanya burr what do you enjoy when I do
when you're not on camera when we're not
on camera we're probably just the same
as you and your friends we just like to
slop out and we like to watch films and
TV and we bought a pizza or we go
shopping or we like to sing in the car
or we like to gossip about boys we do
lots of normal things what has been your
favorite not ever I did one a while a
stick or gentle family day and that was
really lovely because it was when my
family was all together it was me Matt
and Darcy and we had a really nice
summer's day and I know that Dawson
would enjoy watching that one she's
grown up and I really like the videos I
did in New York last year because I
worked really hard to make those really
pretty and I like all the Christmassy
ones I didn't vlog much this year but I
haven't done of vlogs lately I should
make an effort to do more shouldn't I
what made you want to start doing videos
on YouTube well I had a blog I don't
know if you know that where I write
articles on it which is a bit like a
magazine but not really and I was
writing that for six months and one of
my commenters when my readers said I'd
love for you to start videos so I
started it because I've heard bored I
had an office job that I wasn't very
good at I didn't really like very much I
didn't put enough effort into it so when
they weren't looking I would sit and
plan videos and I would go home and film
them upload them and I just sort of got
into it that way because some a reader
suggested I did it what advice would you
give me if I wanted to start a vlog I
don't think you'll like my advice
because I would say I don't think you're
old enough cause you're 9 aren't
someone said to me today what would you
do if in ten year is Darcy asked to
start a vlog channel and that would mean
she was 40 and I said I still think she
were too young but what I would say is
what will be really fun is to film all
the videos so even if you were nine film
or your video can edit them and then
keep them for yourself and then when
you're older upload them because 99% of
the things people say online are really
nice but there's at 1% that can be
really nasty and I know that when I was
19 and when I was even when I was 18 and
19 I still wasn't prepared to deal with
that nastiness so I think whilst you're
little you could just film them and keep
them for yourself and then it loads on
wonder if you wanted to but you still
have all your memories and also with all
that practice by the time you did have a
youtube channel you'd be like the master
of it you feel like zoella already Thank
You Louise are answering all my
questions Thank You Lily for writing
such nice question